[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition du café
politique sur TV Phil 78 revue de presse
de l'actualité des 15 derniers jours en
compagnie d'élus de responsables
politique dans le département et pour
m'accompagner au cours de cette
prochaine demi-heure Philippe benasaya
bonjour bienvenue ici au au bistr du
théâtre à montinil Bretonneux vous êtes
le maire républicain de Bois d'Arcy
bonjour également à Philippe gomard vous
êtes conseiller municipal lut ouvrière à
auberganville porte-parole ibline du
mouvement et délégué CGT également chez
Renault Flin et puis tout à l'heure en
cours d'émission nous rejoindra
également Naim Chili c'est le Président
unfd zivelin on va débuter par de la
politique forcément avec le renoncement
de François Hollande il ne briguera pas
de second mandat manuel Vals lui en
revanche se lance dans la bataille de la
primaire à droite Holland n'y va pas Val
y va vous regardez ça comment peu
importe l'adversaire pour vous non non
je regarde surtout cette fin de
quinquena qui est une qui est une qui
est un un drame quoi trois trois
premierers ministres en 5 ans un premier
ministre en exercice qui s'en va en
pleine en pleine campagne en pleine
bataille j'ai envie de dire là pour le
coup un Premier ministre qui va durer 5
mois qui ne fera absolument rien c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une drôle
de période je crois qu'on est retourné
un peu à la 4e République avec ses
changements de gouvernement tous les ans
ou tous les 2 ans je veux pas faire de
comparaison mais c'est vrai que dans le
précédent quinena quand même on a eu
qu'un premier ministre et et là
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une sacrée
pagil je je regrette ça et je vois ça
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de tristesse
parce que c'est c'est quand même notre
pays qui est en jeu et et les problèmes
ne sont pas réglés j'ai l'impression que
c'est surtout une guerre d'ego plus
qu'une guerre pour la France pour
redresser la France ça c'est triste du
côté ouvrière deux questions peut-être
déjà votre regard sur ce ce gouvernement
actuellement et puis votre regard aussi
sur la question question de la primaire
il y a eu la primaire à droite il va y
avoir une primaire à gauche l' ouvrière
n'y participe pas et se lance seul dans
la bataille donc tout d'abord sur le sur
le Gouvernement sur ce choix de François
Hollande de pas y
aller ce choix de François Hollande en
fait c'est un peu un ciercle PR
préélectoral quo on nous dit Hollande
nous dit aujourd'hui qu'il n'ira pas
mais il a tellement été
déconsidéré par la politique qu'il a
mené il est vomi par la population par
le mond du travail
et concernant la primaire en elle-même
le fait que la primaire mais la primaire
en fait c'est pas c'est pas en fait
c'est c'est c'est une chose des ptin et
qui aujourd'hui nous disent que avec eux
ça va changer en fait c'est pas eux qui
qui décident c'est vraiment patronnat
les financiers des licenciements
aujourd'hui il y a 11000 licenciements
qui sont annoncés chez rbus alors qu'il
y a 2 milliards 7 de
Bénéfic g c'est licenement et c'est pas
eu qui décide c'est voté dans les
conseils d'administration c'est
financier c'est c'est vraiment c'est pas
avec ces gens-là qui se présentent au
primaire de la droite ou de la gauche
que les Chang changeront benasaya votre
réflexion là-dessus ce qui est
intéressant dans les primères de la
gauche il faut savoir aussi respecter
les temps démocratique hein
mais je rappelle quand même que le
patronat le terme patronat est un terme
très très très ciblé très choisi dans le
dans le dans la l'idéologie d'extrême
gauche je rappelle quand même que c'est
quand même l'économie qui fait le social
hein et pas le social qui fait
l'économie donc il faut qu'on ait une
économie très forte pour pouvoir ensuite
après distribuer et ça il faut pas
l'oublier c'est c'est c'est l'objectif
quand même de nos pays de nos
démocraties libéral quand vous parlez du
social justement on peut peut-être
parler aussi de de ce rapport qui a été
fait par le Secours Catholique ces
derniers jours concernant les Yvelines
sur 14000 personnes ou familles qui sont
suivies dans les ivelines la proportion
de fans seul avec enfants rencontré en
point d'accueil euh en forte
augmentation on est passé à 24,5 % la
part de celles qui sont sont hébergés à
l'hôtel aussi passe de 8 à 11 % 3000
personnes sont actuellement logées dans
des hôtels dans le département dont 50 %
d'enfants c'est beaucoup de chiffres
mais derrière tous ces chiffres il y a
des réalités des difficultés quelle
réponse aujourd'hui Philippe gomard on
peut faire pour lutter contre cette
pauvreté qui s'est installée et qu'on a
du mal àir à faire régresser aujourd'hui
cette pauvreté là qu'on constate
aujourd'hui merci vient bien de quelque
part cette misère qui s'accroit c'est le
résultat de des politiques qui ont été
menées
successivement par la gauche ou la
droite c'est de faciliter les
licenciements réduire des emplois dans
la fonction publique de précariser le
travail sur les points de programme
peut-être parce que là on va rentrer
dans dans le cœur des propositions il va
falloir si François Fillon qui est votre
candidat à droite l'emporter en 2017 il
va falloir résoudre ce problème de la
pauvreté on est théoriquement encore
sous un gouvernement de gauche et je
sais que François Hollande 2012 avait
dit qu'il avait avait envie de
réenchanter la France je pense qu'il
nous a désenchanté et c'est vrai que la
misère c'est probablement et là je
partage en partie ce que dit mon mon
camarade euh c'est c'est que c'est vrai
que cette précarité là s'est accrue
alors maintenant il faut voir toujours
ça sur une échelle historique faut
toujours faut pas voir simplement sur
l'immédiateté politique est-ce qu'on est
plus pauvre aujourd'hui qu'on ne l'était
il y a 50 ans ou 60 ans est-ce que nos
démocratie n'ont pas quand même pourvu à
notre bien-être et à notre
épanouissement depuis des 40 50 ans
est-ce que la situation sociale est
meilleure question hein la situation
sociale est meilleure aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était dans les min il y a
50 60 ans 70 ans dans les usines Renault
il y a 40 ans ou 50 ans faut voir ça sur
une échelle historique c'est c'est ça
qui est important je pense on va
accueillir autour de cette table Naim
Chili bonjour vous avez réussi à nous à
nous rejoindre après un petit souci de
transport ça pourrait être un sujet de
de discussion aussi ce matin vous êtes
le président de l'Unef sur l'université
de versaill saqutin en neline Philippe
benass qui représente les républicain
aujourd'hui c'est le maire de boisarcy
et puis Philippe gomard conseiller
municipal lut ouvrière auert jeanville
il est porte parole du mouvement dans le
département nous parlons de de la
pauvreté qui qui progresse et de ce
rapport du Secours Catholique peut-être
profiter de votre présence pour nous
faire part témoigner de la situation
concernant les les étudiants parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de la pauvreté de ces
travailleurs pauvres les étudiants aussi
sont de plus en plus pauvres il y a une
popérisation des étudiants qui sont
obligés de travailler à côté quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui bah
effectivement c'est elle est c'est clair
cette situation notamment on le voit il
y a un certain nombre d'études qui sont
paru récemment l'échec à l'université il
reste toujours aussi élevé on voit qu'il
y a très peu d'étudiants qui arrivent à
terminer leur licence en 3 ans qui
arrivent à valider leur licence en
première année une grande majorité entre
eux échouent lors de leur première année
à faire leur licance en 3 ans pourquoi
parce qu'actuellement on vit dans des
conditions d'études qui sont pas
tenables c'est à la fois les enfilles
qui sont dégradés qui sont délabés une
sur chararge dans les TD et aussi le
fait que oui en tant que jeune ben
actuellement on n pas les moyens pour
pouvoir vivre au quotidien pour pouvoir
aller en cours de manière normale c'est
un étudiant sur deux qui travaille en de
ses études et c'est quelque chose qu'on
a pu voir récemment notamment lors du
mouvement sur la loi travail quoi qu'on
en pense il y avait quand même un
certain RB qui é exprimé de la jeunesse
le fait que on en a marre d'être tout le
temps précarisé on en a marre d'être un
peu parce qu'on est jeune forcément
bisuté à la fois nos études et à la fois
sur le marché de l'emploi donc oui c'est
sûr cette popularisation elle continue
et elle ne risque pas de s'arrêter à l'
ruelle ça ça doit être un point de
programme important pour 2017 je vous
pose la question à l'un et à l'autre la
prise en charge de de cette question
cette détresse de la jeunesse aussi des
étudiants des universités mais c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure je je sans
faire trop de politique sur un sujet sur
la jeunesse mais ce que je disais tout à
l'heure François Hollande avait accxé
son son programme sur la jeunesse et sur
le réenchantement de la France et là je
je note que la jeunesse a été totalement
oublié de ce quinquenard et ça ne veut
pas dire qu'avant c'était encore mieux
et que les autres gouvernements avaient
réglé le problème de la jeunesse et des
étudiants j'ai été étudiant moi aussi
hein il m'est arrivé de faire des études
j'ai l'impression de me retrouver il y a
30 ans 40 ans 30 ans plutôt 30 ans
plutôt quand j'étais étudiant je
travaillais aussi pendant mes études je
faisais des petits boulots quand j'étais
quand j'étais étudiant trouvais ça
plutôt pas mal j'avais des problèmes
pour me loger c'est
vrai j'avais on était dans des
amphibondés pas très pas très pas très
propre souvent j'ai l'impression que la
situation n'a absolument pas changéo la
situation c'est malgré tout dégradée
parce qu'on parle de cette popérisation
mais il y a aussi d'autres problèmes
nouveaux on va pas rentrer dans tous les
détails pour mais mais par exemple la
prostitution des étudiants ça ça
démontre aussi qu'il y a une vraie
difficulté cette prostitution pardon des
des étudiants pour financer leurs études
effectivement tous universitaires on a
fait des petits boulots mais c'était
souvent des compléments on sait qu'il y
a plus ou moins des galères de trouver
un premier logement mais là aujourd'hui
la réalité est quand même encore pire al
ça notre ami pourra peut-être y répondre
parce qu'il est peut-être plus calé que
moi sur sur cette émergence et peut-être
aussi l'émergence avec les réseaux
sociaux ont fait que peut-être la la
prostitution s'est développée beaucoup
plus facilement dans le milieux
étudiants que qu'avant je ne sais pas si
le
si je me souviens plus en tout cas si
c'était un sujet déjà dans il y a 30 ans
mais forcément si vous si c'est un
phénomène qui est pérenne la
prostitution dans le milieu étudiant si
c'est pas un ép phénomène ou un
phénomène je n'en sais rien mais si
c'est un phénomène c'est que on revient
à l'idée de tout à l'heure sur la
précarité qui touche également cette
jeunesse qui a été totalement totalement
abandonné j'ai l'impression que rien ne
change en fait dans le milieu dans le
milieu universitaire et et dans la
jeunesse aujourd'hui pour l ouvrière la
prise en compte des problématiques des
étudiants vous allez aussi dans le cadre
de la campagne oui bien sûr toute
façonjà on dénonce un peu laette
situation ces étudiants depuis depuis
2007 avec la réforme des universités il
y a une autonomie financière qui fait
que beaucoup de d'universités se
retrouvent en déficit et qui font des
choix budgétaires justement ce étudis
qui ont des difficultés hein et sans
compter qu'il y a 30000 étudiants qui
rentrent dans les universités tous les
ans
ben pour faire face à ça il faut des
moyens aujourd'hui c'est le contraire
qu'on fait donne moins de moyens au
étudiants et en plus ce n'est pas que
seulement au moment où on rentre
dansuniversité il faut voir le problème
de l'éducation national en général parce
que même dès la primaire il faudrait
justement mettre des moyens aujourd'hui
dans la primaire il faudrait mettre des
moyens pourendre du
langage
inégalités c'est encore derni commence
dès le départ dès le départ dans
l'éducation nationale et ce problème on
peut voir de manière globale de manière
large on dit les ils sont ét les jeunes
ont été oubliés pendant 5 ans je suis
bien d'accord avec vous mais je pense
qu'il est encore aujourd'hui quand on
voit les débats sur la présidentielle
c'est soit le service militaire
obligatoire pour tout soit
sélectionuniversité je pense pas que
c'est des débat très sain et qui
s'intéresse vraiment aux problématiques
de la jeunesse un peu caricaturale mais
vous avez en partie r c'est ce qu'on dit
et encore qu quand on évoque la question
de la jeunesse
puis puisque souvent ne l'évoque pas du
tout on aurait parlé plutôt de comment
favoriser l'accès à l'autonomie comment
pouvoir que les jeunes puissent se
soigner puisqueactuellement au moins un
jeune sur trois renonce à se soigner du
fait que cela coûte trop cher bref
toutes ces problématiques on les voit
pas actuellement sur devant de la scène
et nous ce qu'on va mettre en avant
c'est le fait que bah oui actuellement
dans les faculté la situation n'est pas
optimale il y a une crise budgétaire
depuis un C N d'années il y a plus en
plus d'étudiants qui accédé à SP
supériur quelque chose de positif c'est
on a pas plus d'étudiant qui réussit
c'est-à-dire que bah encore c'est c'est
un peu parce que on est plus nombreux
mais parce qu'on a pas forcément les
mêmes capacités financière budgéire
culturelle pour pouvoir réussir c'est
toujours une minorité qui a accèdé à un
diplôme à la fin et donc c'est face à
cela nous propose réinvestir dans
l'ignement supérieur pour permettre leur
suite de tous et aussi en tant que jeune
pas être obligé de bah voilà re buté
tout au long de sa vie avant on galérer
effectivement en tant qu'étudiant mais
aujourd'hui une chose nouvelle c'est
qu'on galère aussi quand on accède au
marché de l'emploi on ensene les CDD on
enseène les stages et c'est un véritable
parcours du combattant pour finalement
arriver à un emploi stable et face à
cela il y a une vraie un vrai effort qui
doit être mené de la part des politiques
qui pas du tout fait puisque dans les
discours comme je disais soit on parle
pas de la jeunesse so on en parle de
manière totalement caricaturelle je
trouve que vous êtes très peu mobilisé
quand même sur ce qu Ken sur T ces sujet
là par exemple vous beauc mobilisé dans
le passé man frand pourrait dire
contraire pour la loi de travail on pas
j'ai pas trouvéait d'énormes grandes
manifestations de mobilisation mais je
sais pas je me trompe peut-être mais
j'ai j'ai pas vu une forte mobilisation
des organisations syndicales vousvez éé
plus indulgent avec ce gouvernement
peutreutê jeis c'est caricatural de se
dire que parce que c'est un gouvernement
de gauche on aurait été on aurait été
sympa avec eux la politique a été
clairement menée c'est pas une une
politique quielle est en faveur des
jeunes les seules mesures qui ont été
mises en avant l'augmentation des
bourses c'est des mesures parce qu'elles
ont été arrachées par les jeunes
justement soit lors des élections éantes
soit lors demobilisation le moment sur
la loi travail a montré clairement que
la jeunesse est au-delà de l'unfin
quelle qu'elle soit la jeunesse apprenti
et C et cetera voulait faire entendre sa
voix avait conscience que ces conditions
de vie et d'étude n'étaient pas
optimales et se mobiliser du coup en
conséquence on a arraché un certain
nombre de choses les 500 millions
d'euros que le gouvernement a a a mis en
place à la suite de de ce mouvement ils
ne sont pas tombés par hasard ils sont
tombés parce que je s'est mobilisé nous
on a pendant 5 ans fait ce travail
d'interpel politique ona durant les 5
ans à venir on l'a fait durant sarczi on
l'a fait durant Hollande et donc nous on
est là pour justement interpeller les
poétiques actuellement c'est pas par
exemple pareil en rétablissant le blues
à l'école ou une histoire du roman
national qu'on arrivera à répondre aux
problématiques de la jeunesse c'est un
peu au-delà et c'est là-dessus que nous
on veut mettre l'accent au-delà des des
questions d'éducation maintenant on va
parler de de ce monde du travail aussi
et la situation au sein du groupe
Renault on va profiter de votre présence
Renault qui a annoncé que les salaires
devraient augmenter au cours des trois
prochaines années en refermant la page
de modération salariale sur la période
2014-2016 est-ce que vous envoyez les
signes bah pour l'instant il y a des
discussions en cours pour l'instant rien
de concret n'a été annoncé sur des
augmentations de salaires général pour
les salariés pour le monde du travail
euh aujourd'hui il parle vaguement de
mmentation individuelle mais on n sait
pas plus euh si c'est dans le même c'est
si ce qu'ils annoncent va dans le même
même sillage ce qui a été fait
auparavant il faut pas en espérer
beaucoup les salaires ils augmentent pas
depuis depuis de nombreuses années et
nous moi en tant que délégué
CGT mes camarades de travail on pense
que il faut pas en attendre grandchose
de ces discussions hein ce qui peut
changer les choses si les salaires ils
pourront augmenter que si vraiment les
salariés ben ils montrent leur colère
pour de véritables augmentations de
salaire qui est des mobilisations des
luttes sociales qui fera que les
salaires augmenteront aujourd'hui des
discussions en cours et ben voilà il
n'aboutissent sur pas grand-chose
au-delà des discussions sur le salaire
on a surtout entendu parler aujourd'hui
dans cette précampagne électorale de de
temps de travail est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter le temps de travail par
exemple le temps de travail ben c'est
c'est VO c'est l'utre boutre l'autre
bout de des discussions ou les les
patrons hein que ça soit chez Renault ou
ailleurs ils veulent augmenter le temps
de travail pour augmenter la
surexploitation c'està dire que nous
faire travailler plus pour gagner autant
si voir sinon moins hein c'est en fait
c'est le but c'est c'est de faire
grossir les profits euh voilà essayer de
que les actionnaires s'en mettent un peu
plus dans les poches mais voilà c'est le
le le le véritable sens de de cette
discussion sur le temps de travail c'est
vraiment augmenter la surexploitation
des salariés Philippe benasa votre
candidat républicain François Fillon qui
porte cette déréglementation du temps de
travail vous la soutenez c'est une bonne
position alors d'abord il se passera
rien pour répondre un peu à sur sur les
salaires il se passera rien pendant 5
mois donc il faut rien attendre ça c'est
on est dans une on est dans le monetime
comme on dit dans le dans le sport il
faudra attendre les élections
présidentielles pour pour et le prochain
gouvernement et le prochain président
parce que je pense que voilà prochain
président prochain
président on le sait depuis quelques
jours maintenant euh donc voilà il
faudra attendre faudra attendre le
prochain le prochain le prochain
gouvernement
non on est le seul pays au monde à avoir
fait les 35 heur donc soit on est
extrêmement intelligent extrêmement
lucide et soit on est complètement à
côté de la plaque je pense qu'on est
complètement à côté de la plaque parce
que si les 35 heur avaient marché ça se
verrait aujourd'hui je crois que le
chômage augmenta depuis 5 ans 10 ans 15
ans 20 ans donc j'ai l'impression que
les 35 he n'ont rien réglé si on ve
passer aux 32h autant mettre la clé sous
la porte tout de suite je pense donc on
passe à quoi 48 ou je pense que l'erreur
de la droite vous voyez je suis très
lucide hein je je je suis pas je suis
pas un un militant mais l'erreur de la
droite c'est de pas avoir supprimé les
35 he je pense qu'il va falloir revenir
à un temps de travail un petit peu plus
important ou alors laisser le choix par
par branche aux entreprise de revenir ou
pas sur les trans je crois qu'il faut un
peu de liberté dans ce pays le problème
le problème si je un peu de politique là
pour le coup c'est que le problème de la
gauche c'est que son souci
d'égalitarisme freine et bloque un petit
peu les les libertés individuelles et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut que ce pays
retrouve un peu de liberté notamment sur
le plan du travail sur le plan de
l'emploi laissons les entreprises qui
créent de la richesse c'est pas l'état
qui crée la richesse c'est l'entreprise
qui crée la richesse laissons les
entreprises régler ce problème là par
branche et puis après voilà mais surtout
si c'est possible si François Fillon
m'écoutait mais ça m'étonnerait surtout
supprimer les 35 heur en tout cas Suppr
mais ce carcan voilà cette cette valeur
absolue que sont les 35 he mais
travailler plus pour gagner plus des 39
he payer 39 ou des 39 pay libre pour
gagner plus vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'està-dire laisser laisser les
entreprises travailler comme elles le
souhaitent voir éventuellement
travailler plus pourquoi pas pour gagner
plus est-ce qu'on a décidé de s'en
sortir ou pas voilà donc si la réponse
est les 35H a priori non puisque ça n'a
pas marché jusqu'à maintenant donc
laissons un petit peu les entreprises
régler ses problèmes par branche vous
qui êtes étudiant ain vous serez sur le
monde du travail marché du travail
travailleer plus travailleer moins votre
regard je regarde un peu mon regard sur
ce débat c'est un peu celui aussi j'ai
sur la jeunesse on a les mêmes
propositions un peu caricatural de ces
dernières années qu' on regarde le débat
et la primère à droite est passée on a
eu le temps de voir chaque candidat de
droit de s'exprimer ses positions
là-dessus si on est un peu dans le même
schéma de ces dernières années on parle
encore que il faut régler le ton travail
et C et cetera mais à aucun moment et
c'est pareil qu'on garde les prion à
gauche d'ailleurs c'est on imagine le
monde qui vient c'està-d on pas pas l'AC
de la trans écologique on parle pas de
la transition numérique on prend pas en
compte finalement toutes les formes de
travail qui sont en train d'émerger
l'ubérisation et cetera et cetera on
prend pas en compte aussi comment le
monde du travail va évoluer durant les
prochaines années ça c'est inquiétant
puisqueon raisonne avec les mêmes
pensées les mêmes schémas un peu
caricaturau sans essayer d'imaginer
nouvelles idées pour bah voilà comment
on va permettre à tous de travailler
demain qu'on va permettre à tous de
travailler dignement c'est un peu le
regard que je porte là-dessus c'est un
débat souvent avec les mêmes personnes
et souvent avec les mêmes idées pas
forcément intéressant du coup qui pose
pas forcément les débats là-dessus c'est
notamment la jeunesse de faire émerger
de nouvelles prop question je pense sur
Ben comment on réinvente les formes de
production de demain comment on
réinvente comment on réinvente pardon
des formes de production plus équitables
plus responsables pour permettre à tous
de vivre dignement et aussi de prendre
en compte je les nouveaux défis de
demain la transition écologique
transition numérique ça pour le moment
on l'entend pas trop évoquer dans les
débats donc 32 35 39h ça c'est pas ma
position ce que je dis c'est que il ne
faut pas seulement raisonner en terme de
durée de temps de travail c'est aussi
audelà sur les formes de travail qu'il
fautonner mais après non ce que je dis
en tout cas c'est que après c'est
actuellement au salari tout cas je vais
pas parler à leur place au salariés dire
ce qu'ils pensent en tout cas en MO
enant jeune le regard que j'ai sur ce
débat c'est qu' il est assez assez
caricatur avec les mêmes dogme d'un côté
et de l'autre on va abattre les 35 heur
on sait que c'est ce que pense la droite
je pense pas que c'est forcément les
meilleures solutions pour l'avenir on
termine comme à chaque fois ce café
politique avec un dernier tour de table
ce que vous retenez chacun de
l'actualité des 10 15 derniers jours
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué dans
l'actualité oh là plusieurs choses
plusieurs choses sportivement je suis un
peu déçu par ce qui s'est passé mardi
soir par des prince pour PSG mais ça
c'est le qui parle des réalités parlons
sérieux non moi ce qui m'a plu c'est
quand même malgré mes réserves la bonne
tenue de la primaire de la de la droite
il faut faut être honnête c'était pas
notre c'était pas notre exercice le plus
le plus simple et a priori ça s'est
quand même plutôt bien passé il y a eu 4
millions d'électeurs bon voilà il y a
pas eu il y a eu des vrais débats avec
de de des rassemblements des des
incohérences des cohérences des des
cohésions mais ça c'est plut passer je
souhaite que la prière de gauche se
passe très très bien le défi doit être
relevé quand même parce que 4 million
d'électeurs c'est beaucoup je je
souhaite que les gauches parce que là
pour le coup il y a plusieurs gauches
qui vont s'affronter dans cette primaire
fasse une bonne primaire et et que le
débat démocratique se déroule bien
ensuite il y a plein d'autres choses la
situation internationale me préoccupe
énormément ce qui se passe en Syrie
surtout ça c'est c'est à Halep je suis
très inquiet aussi sur les minorités en
Orient aussi qui me qui me qui
m'interpelle depuis déjà des mois mais
surtout depuis depuis quelques semaines
et puis voilà quoi il y a plein plein
d'autres choses mais ça sera peut-être
l'objet d'une autre émission pere tout à
fait on aura l'occasion de revenir sur
tous ces sujets c'est sûr dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois ce
que vous retenez dans l'actualité Chili
bah très brièvement ce que je retiens
c'est qu' alors qu'il y a 6 mois une
jeunesse qui se mobilise massivement
soit en se mobilisant directement soit à
travers les enquêtes toutpignion
montrant un peu son rbol et son
ressentil la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui ben la thématique de la
jeunesse elle est pas extrêmement
présente dans les débats publics soit la
question de la présidentielle même quand
on voit la déclaration de François
Hollande alors qu'il annonce qu'il se
représentera pas il s'autooficide de son
bilan sur l'éducation on pourrait avoir
un bilan un peu plus critique donc ça ce
que je retiens des débats un peu hors
sol qui n'évoquent pas forcément les
vrais sujets et qui quand il les évoqu
il n'évoqu pas forcément de la bonne
manière je disais quand on parle du
temps de travail qu'on qu'on évoque pas
les changements de mode de production
c'est un peu compliqué je trouve qu'on
évoque la jeunesse seulement sous le
prisme de il faut l'éduquer via un
service militaire obligatoire je pense
pas que c'est la bonne solution donc
c'est ce que nous on fera cette jeunesse
c'est les étudiants c'est interpeller
faire entendre notre voix et montrer
qu'il y a d'autres solutions qui
existent que les jeunes les jeunes
demandent autre chose qu'un service
servic obligatoire ou je ne sais quoi
d'autre et c'est un peu tout ce qu'on va
faire durant les prochains mois les
prochaines semaines très bien et pour
vous pour conclure bah pour conclure
voilà on on le voit on l'a bien vu dans
les débats que ça soit à droite à gauche
voir l'extrême droite qui aspire tous à
gérer cette
société la gérer mais pour les intérêts
des plus riches voit même le Front
National qui se dit hors système et ben
il aspire aussi à gérer ces sociétés là
il en profite même il est englué dans
des histoires des
soupçons sur le sur leur financement de
leur partis sur les régionales et
législative on le voit ces gens-là et
ben il ils aspirent tous à gérer cette
société en fonction des intérêts des
plus richiches des capitalistes et moi
ce que je peux dire c'est que à
l'approche des élections ben le seul
vote qui sera vraiment utile ça sera de
voter le camp le camp des travailleurs
le vote Nathalie
pour
justement retrouver la dignité des
travailleurs qu's affirment un peu leurs
idées en votant ouvrière dans pour le
camp des travaille la campagne est
lancée voilà chacun soutient son
candidat c'est parti pour cette campagne
2017 merci à tous les trois en tout cas
d'être venu pour ce café politique
prochain numéro ce sera le 21
décembre
[Musique]